but what I've over time started to
realize also is like it goes back to
kind of uh why we want to search some of
these companies investing in other
people's companies is great and
obviously the power law takes over and
when that occurs uh it's an amazing and
Angel Investing can be really profitable
but actually you're much more likely to
be able to take you know fifty a hundred
thousand dollars start a business and
get to like a million dollars in revenue
and throw off 500 to 700 000 in profit
year after year after year and do it
with like a very high degree of uh of uh
probability of success and so in some
way like what's better than Angel
Investing in other people's ideas it may
actually be just like Angel Investing in
your own ideas or your own companies and
so that's really where I've been focused
is like yes I will still on occasion
invest in other companies but now I want
to start these businesses and I look at
it as
what is the competitive Advantage we
have Capital but we also have
distribution and so if you have capital
and distribution you basically just need
like a decent idea and you need an
absolute killer operator and if you can
find those two things combine it with
the capital and distribution you got a
good chance of being able to make some
money
[Music]
all right we got an episode out here
with pomp Anthony pompliano who you may
know as the Bitcoin guy he's huge all
over YouTube Twitter everywhere else he
uh came on we're actually going to do
this as a two-part episode because at
the beginning it was all business we
were business in the front we were
talking about this crazy million dollar
biology bet where he's betting that
Bitcoin is going to a million dollars in
the next 90 days we talk about that why
biology thinks it what we think about
the BET and pomp does a you know I don't
know econ 101 where he explains what's
going on with the banking system from
his perspective that was good and here's
the thing though in that episode the
whole episode is about something that's
going to happen inside the next 90 days
so if you're gonna like it is a little
fearful listening to it and so actually
listen to the whole thing because and do
it now because we're talking about
something that's happening in 90 days
and then go ahead the second episode was
way more fun and it was pretty wild go
ahead we talk about his business Empire
you know what he's building and why he's
building it that way why he gave back
all the money from his fund and shut
that down why he is huge turned off all
his advertisers millions of dollars of
advertised what he's doing instead so we
talked about that and then we talked
about and then it went off the wall and
uh the the Pod got a little crazy but in
a great way I think people are gonna
You're Gonna Love part two he broke down
like all of his businesses and how they
work it's very impressive it was pretty
wild
um and uh it was it was he's impressive
he's significantly more impressive than
a lot of people think I think because
there's way more behind the scenes
pretty funny stories which pop is
usually he's pretty buttoned up on his
on his main Channel because he's talking
Finance he's talking serious but he told
some pretty funny stories so the second
uh part two is the more fun episode part
one is the more serious episode I think
you'll like them both and we have to
remind you guys that our episodes we
work really really hard and unlike every
other type of podcast Out There Our
stuff's not free but you don't pay with
money all you have to do is go to our
YouTube page we call this
the gentleman's agreement what is it the
ladies understanding the ladies
understanding you go to our YouTube page
and the reason it's called that is
because it's an understanding it's an
agreement we can't be there behind your
screen to check this otherwise we would
but everyone's doing it so just go ahead
and do it and click subscribe on YouTube
and then just go ahead and do that on
Spotify and iTunes because
the more you do that the more our volume
goes up and we get more downloads and we
could do keep doing this type of stuff
pump ain't gonna come on to episodes
like this if we don't have a big
listenership same with all the other
guests all right enjoy
can we talk about instead of value uh
ruining we talk about value creation
because pomp owns like four companies I
think that I wanted to ask him about and
my fight or flight mode is like too much
right now that I need like I need like a
Rags or riches story I need something
interesting I need I need to tell me how
he makes makes the paper now because I
need to calm down I need to meditate by
stop telling me how he makes income
um is that all right Sean yeah but but
what's your question how do you want to
frame it
well so pomp he has from what I
understand you have four or five
different companies and you have this
office in Miami and you have like it
feels like you have at first I was gonna
call it a mini Empire but it doesn't
sound so many uh actually uh it sounds
medium Empire medium Empire yeah uh
maybe big Empire I don't know can you
explain what are like the things that
you got going on
yeah so you know from my career uh if
you really think about there's kind of
three stages to some degree at first it
was like Hey how do I build companies
and I basically had enough success where
I was like okay maybe I'm not like
horrible at this but I definitely don't
know how to like build companies to
scale Etc uh that led to uh Facebook
where like that was kind of my
equivalent of like an MBA right I
literally was with all these super
talented people uh in 2014 2015.
um I was put on a number of different
projects where I got exposed to Mark
Zuckerberg and Cheryl Sandberg and a
bunch of the leadership of the the
company and I just learned a lot it was
like the best learning experience
possible
um and shortly thereafter uh I started
investing and when I started investing
it was kind of like I didn't have an
idea to start a company so like oh let's
try this investing thing and I really
enjoyed doing it uh ended up building
two different Asset Management firms
um and like it's fun but like the
product is kind of money and you get to
work on a bunch of different ideas but I
think that I keep coming back to an idea
like venture capital is such a slugging
percentage game that which you end up
doing is you end up actually playing an
access game almost more than you do
playing a business game and what I mean
by that is outside of the maybe the big
five or six Venture Capital funds
once a company gets de-risked it is all
access right it is literally who do you
know how do you get into a deal how do
you actually get an allocation whatever
and like that's fun but that to me is
more of like a kind of a status type
thing of like oh what do these people
think of me will they invite me into the
deal and like that maybe is like an
underbelly of the Venture Capital
industry and so simultaneous to building
those Asset Management firms I started
creating content on the internet and in
hindsight like it was optimized
initially for learning then it kind of
Switched like oh there's a lot of deal
flow that comes from this and so I like
took a little bit more seriously and
then there was this like final
transition like oh these are like
businesses right and I think the big aha
that I had was historically you built a
company by building the product and then
going and looking for customers now you
can find the customers and then build
the product and so that's essentially
what we've done is we've built this very
very large audience
um you know the podcast is 25 million
downloads last year YouTube's half a
million subscribers uh one day I think
you guys are gonna pass me so keep going
uh the email is Big Twitter's big Etc is
there a podcast are you bigger than us
right now are you trying to flex on us
or are we already bigger downloads
uh ranges from a hundred thousand to 150
000 per episode and if that's uh so the
the RSS feed the actual pod is in the
hundred thousand ish range sometimes
more sometimes less and then the YouTube
videos 20 to 50 000. so that's why we
say 100 to 150 000 downloads so you guys
will do more than me on individual
episodes but I have like this crazy
power law like we just put up an
interview on YouTube it's got you know
100 000 views in the first 12 uh hours
right so it's like very much
concentrated on like the long tail
um which is like also interesting right
like would you rather have the
consistent 50 to 100 000 YouTube and and
podcast or would you rather have the
breakout like million you know views
plus every month or so like this yeah so
maybe maybe you'll catch up to us one
day I don't know
uh so the general idea has just been
like how do you build those businesses
um and really it's like once you know
who the audience is you can go and build
products but like I very much look at it
as a game and it goes back to the whole
idea like I don't have Hobbies right
like this is what I do uh in my free
time and I really enjoy doing it and so
we've built a number of different
businesses some of them have been bigger
than others uh but really it's like if
you have distribution then you can build
companies in the 21st century and we see
you know really really big creators
doing this I tend to think of anyone can
do it
um and then I guess what are the
businesses
uh so there's the media company itself
uh then we have a uh with the two
aspects you have at you have so yeah
let's just listen so number one media
company that has that has advertising is
that a substantial size business it used
to have advertising it was a very
substantial business uh it probably was
one of the best monetized podcasts in
the world based on the audience to
revenue uh it was a big podcast and so
both on the revenue side and also the
the downloads
um I turned all the ads off and I think
there was really two things that fed
into it one was when you have an
Advertiser usually you just go and you
find companies that you like their
product you then say hey I use this
product you guys should check it out and
that's like fine if you're doing like a
bar of soap or you're doing like liquid
death or you know like whatever the
normal product is the problem in finance
is like people put their money into a
product that you then share and so
you're essentially like renting your
reputation to someone else right and you
have no control over the business you
don't know what they're doing and then
it's not like oh I bought this you know
chair they got recommended or I bought
this sweatshirt that uh Sean and Sam
said was really cool I don't like it
like uh the idiots right but like I'm
not that worried about it when somebody
puts their money into a product then all
of a sudden it's a whole different game
and so I just didn't want to be in that
world anymore especially when a lot of
them are crypto companies and crypto
companies kept blowing up Etc but the
second thing that I realized from a
business opportunity standpoint is when
I got rid of all of the advertising I
knew that we would take a massive hit we
have a team we've got an office like all
this stuff and so I had to commit to
personally covering everything so like
once I made the decision I've been
losing money every month but I'm doing
it because the bigger opportunity is to
actually own the products and services
that you put through the distribution so
think of it like you guys will get paid
as a podcast host for an ad they might
pay you one dollar to read the ad but
they're making three to five dollars on
the back end as their return on
Advertising now if you can cut out the
middleman and you can just own the
product or service that's a way better
deal the reason why most people don't do
it is because they don't have the skill
set or the interest in actually building
the product or the service and so I
basically just was like look we kind of
like figured out how to do Advertising
based content I want a hard challenge I
want to do something that is going to be
by most people's account stupid to give
up all this revenue and go try this
um and like it's one intellectually
stimulating but two is if we figure it
out it'll be a way bigger business and
it'll be a much more sustainable
resilient thing over the long run it's
just you got to be able to weather the
kind of bumpy transition in between
adbase to you know owning the products
and services yourself
so we have fund we have Media company
which sometimes does sometimes doesn't
actually make Revenue then we have hold
on hold on the fund didn't you give all
the money back aren't you no longer in
the fund so there's two different Asset
Management firms one was a joint venture
with Morgan Creek capital a hedge fund
um we invested all the capital uh and uh
um yeah investing in companies like
coinbase and uh we bought some Bitcoin
those types of things uh and you get a
cut if it ever does well correct and
then
um I had a second asset measure for most
one of the first people to do a rolling
fund on Angel list which I found was an
incredible product for somebody who has
a small team and kind of wants to punch
above their weight
um and so I think we grew it into like
maybe the third biggest uh rolling fund
on the platform at the time
um made a bunch of Investments and then
I just got to the point where I started
to do the math and I was like what do I
enjoy investing in I enjoy investing in
like the pre-seed seat I actually don't
like doing like series B series C stuff
again because it's more like this like
status and access game I enjoy meeting
someone who's like I have an idea idea
and like talking to them and trying to
figure out like is this a Bible idea
what are the first steps and so if you
actually look at the math if you can
afford to personally invest in those
deals a lot of times it's actually
better economically to personally invest
than it is to invest out of the fun
because of the way that the carry works
and kind of the management fees Etc and
so it was like if I invest personally
rather than do the fund and also now I
don't have to spend time on LPS on the
updates like do all the things that go
into managing a fund I get time back
plus I could make more money like I'll
always pick that and so I gave back all
of the uninvested capital out of that
fund and then now just do all of my
investing personally and do you do big
checks or is it like the normal like 15
to 30 000 Angel check no I'll do bigger
than that
um but what I've over time started to
realize also is like it goes back to
kind of uh why we want to search some of
these companies investing in other
people's companies is great and
obviously the power law takes over and
when that occur uh it's an amazing and
Angel Investing can be really profitable
but actually you're much more likely to
be able to take you know fifty a hundred
thousand dollars start a business and
get to like a million dollars in revenue
and throw off 500 to 700 000 in profit
year after year after year and do it
with like a very high degree of uh of uh
probability of success and so in some
way like what's better than Angel
Investing in other people's ideas it may
actually be just like Angel Investing in
your own ideas or your own companies and
so that's really where I've been focused
is like yes I will still on occasion
invest in other companies but now I want
to start these businesses and I look at
it as
what is the competitive Advantage we
have Capital but we also have
distribution and so if you have capital
and distribution you basically just need
like a decent idea and you need an
absolute killer operator and if you can
find those two things combine it with
the capital and distribution you got a
good chance of being able to make some
money and so you have and by the way
what's your biggest Angel investment or
what will end up be so far the most
successful one you think
um
some of the big I mean Bitcoin obviously
is probably the one that uh will end up
making the most money uh both in terms
of the amount of money I invested but
also uh kind of just the aggregate
dollar uh value it'll be worth I tend to
be in Sean's camp like the dollars
aren't going to matter it's going to be
the Bitcoin
um I I think that some that people will
find interesting I don't know the exact
math on all of them and one of the
things is when it's your own money you
probably pay less attention than when
it's a fund right because you're kind of
just like oh I invested that money's
gone uh hopefully I get some back later
um but I invested in varda uh Deli in
and a bunch of those guys
um they're doing kind of uh space
manufacturing I find that really
fascinating
um a friend and I uh we invested in
something called Everly well uh based
out of Austin actually they do like at
home diagnostic testing
um I invested in uh Howard lerman's new
company Rome uh they're kind of building
like a workspace for remote teams kind
of a zoom and slack type killer that
seems to be doing uh very very well
um and a whole host of other ones
so all right so we're and then you go so
you got the fun in investing you got bad
thing Media Company you also have crypto
Academy you have crypto jobs which
parlayed now into like a proper
recruiting service yeah those three so
you can basically think of uh the
inflection points business a business
called inflection points um you can
think of that almost as like it's become
a holding company for all these
different products and services in a
specific vertical so I'm fascinated with
Mark Leonard I don't know if you guys
know uh constellation software he
basically buys these like vertically uh
vertical specific software companies
um well what happens if you don't have a
uh holding company that ends up buying
across the different verticals what if
you just have a holding company within a
specific vertical and so that's
basically what we've built we have a job
Marketplace that companies can go list
their open roles they pay for it we then
use the distribution to drive traffic
people uh can go get a job we also have
that's uh that's pop crypto jobs.com
right that's that's correct
okay and that that's like a pretty basic
business it's just a job board think of
a job board right that's how we got
started with just a job board got it we
launched it it got to like fifty
thousand dollars in monthly Revenue
pretty much in like the first like four
weeks uh and it was like okay we have a
business here right we can go and we can
try to scale this thing
um we then bought a recruiting company
kind of traditional Headhunters uh proof
of talent is the name of that business
um and so you can do like self-serve you
can go and list the jobs and people will
come to you or you can go and you can
work with the recruiters they just take
a percentage of the first year uh fee
then we started doing corporate training
so there was a very large company that
came to us and was like Hey can you
train our people
um and so we got into that business uh
ended up growing that to seven figures
in Revenue
um and then we just started a research
business the research business think of
it as like buy side research so uh you
pay a subscription fee
um and they deliver research uh kind of
a couple times a week uh called reflex
can you say but that's yeah you say what
that was called so that one's like that
one's like a perfect example right so
reflexivity research is within that
whole company but I think is a perfect
example of like what I want to do now
over and over and over again uh so if
you have an idea please reach out to
myself uh Sam orshawn but um
will Clemente is a a young guy in the
Bitcoin crypto world uh has done really
great analysis I've worked with them for
about a year I know that he's hard
working how did you find that guy he was
like in college right when you found him
that guy was great working at Target
he was working at Target literally he
was literally working at Target and he
would go into this story couldn't end
either way this is gonna end wonderfully
or not
Bitcoin researcher was working at Target
uh all right this is either a great
Underdog Story or it's gonna be how
could you guys trust this guy well I
don't remember every single detail but
he had like I don't know a couple
thousand maybe a thousand followers on
Twitter he was going into the bathroom
at Target and like tweeting like Bitcoin
charts and stuff and so I met him
because of the stuff he was tweeting and
then was in the bathroom no online
hey you know like what's your background
what do you do like also and he's like
I'm literally like in the bathroom at
Target tweeting on my lunch break right
or whatever I was like all right like
that's pretty cool
um and so we just started to you know
kind of uh interact online then I
started to bring him on the podcast and
just like I got to know him and it was
like okay like this kid is smart uh he's
young so he doesn't have a ton of
experience but like his compounding uh
rate of learning was like off the charts
he would like read a book in two or
three days and then like send me hey
here's all the things I learned from the
book and then you'd like read another
one and do it again it was just like all
right the trajectory of this is not
linear this is very much like
compounding or exponential like this is
another way I want to spend time with
why is a guy who's this smart at this
into learning working at Target in the
first place like was he just not
interested in school but only interested
in blockchain what why does this happen
he was in college this was like his like
job while he was in college was like you
just go to like the local businesses
right you got a job at Target cool so he
ended up dropping out of college and
kind of like bet on himself he got a job
eventually we're like hey maybe we
should like start a company together and
so we figured out kind of the structure
of the business
um we put some money into the business
and we in the first six months got to
you know 100K of ARR and I think that we
will be at maybe three or four hundred K
of ARR after the first you know call it
nine months and then I think that maybe
we can get somewhere around a million
dollars in the first year and so it's
like if you can do this product by the
way this product I'm looking at the site
so it I I used to own this thing called
Trends trends.com and we got that to be
a good business but you guys are doing
very similar but you're making not I
made a mistake of being broad you're
doing just crypto it's 2500 a year and
what is it just a Weekly Newsletter no
you get like anywhere between four to
six different research reports per week
and then there's a weekly what we call
like an analyst call so we've got a
bunch of these young people who are like
crypto native kids right I'll use kids
because they're like under the age of 25
most of them uh and they're super super
smart they're like in all the Discord
channels and they really understand like
what is happening in the community and
then you take someone like me who can
help them wrap that into something that
can be consumed by large family offices
hedge funds you know large asset
managers individual investors Etc and so
not only do you get the research reports
but you also get that Weekly call where
uh you get to get on and just ask them
questions they're like and they're
they're writing the reports Jason here
from JPMorgan
um just quick question for uh come squat
69 uh you you mentioned that you were
we literally have like public company
CEOs who are subscribers and they get on
the call and they're like trying to like
you know learn and all this stuff and uh
when you have these businesses I think
that there's like pros and cons to these
like internet uh Native businesses that
are starting especially with young
people who want to work who who kind of
have this desire to kind of push forward
the good thing is like they're young
they're like too naive to know all the
things that would stop someone else from
doing it they have a lot of time on
their hands and like frankly they're
willing to make mistakes right they
don't get embarrassed because they did
something you're just like hey don't do
that they're like okay like thanks and
then just go and do something else the
downside to it is like at one point we
literally had to have like a little bit
of an internal session I'm like hey
here's how you write you know like like
a grammar and like here's how to like
use punctuation and spacing and like all
these types of things and so you go into
these businesses understanding that like
it's all about momentum and then you
have to look for the rate of uh or the
compounding rate of learning and if you
can set it up correctly these businesses
can grow to be pretty substantial they
can be profitable and also the thing I
enjoy the most is like if I could go
back and be 22 again like I don't want
to go get a [__] job right I want to
like kind of bet on myself and use this
internet thing and try to make money and
make more money than I can make at a
regular job and so in many of our
different businesses we have people who
have made enormous amounts of money
compared to what they could make if they
went and got a normal job doing the
exact same skill but it all comes down
to incentives and so in every business
what I try to do is I try to create
upside where we take a portion of
Revenue or profit depending on the
business we put it into a pool and then
we try to split that among the team and
so if you have a profitable business and
you're able to incentivize people and
you're like hey when you win I win and
when I win you win people will do
incredible quali and velocity of work
because ultimately the capitalistic
incentive takes over and they just
simply want to make money and they want
to do good work to make that money and
so it ends up aligning interest and
these businesses can absolutely explode
but why do five things instead of just
one thing that that could maybe like
just grow a little bit faster or have
more of your focus I am doing one thing
so I think this is like a different way
of looking at it I'm providing capital
and distribution that's the only thing I
do right when I start the research
business will and the people he has
hired they're doing the research they're
doing kind of all the different things
I'm really really good at putting
together the deals in the capital and
then pushing a high quality product
through my distribution and hopefully
that'll grow to not just be my
distribution be other people's
distribution but I couldn't run the
recruiting business I couldn't run the
research business I couldn't run you
know a lot of these different businesses
I have to kind of stay within that
Circle of competence and it's just like
Provide Capital have a huge megaphone
and I guess maybe pick correctly right
pick the people that you're going to do
it with correctly and then just like get
out of the way and let them be great at
what they do and if you have the Stars
aligned like they can become pretty big
businesses Sean and I are kind of in
like a similar spot as you and the thing
I keep asking myself is like
yeah this is awesome uh we you know and
Sean and I each separately are doing
it's very similar to things as you but I
think to myself but when are people
gonna stop listening to me when when am
I not going to be cool anymore do does
that do you get that fear of like uh
your clout won't matter
well I I think that I've now been on the
internet long enough where like I've
gone through Peaks and valleys like 2021
I could have literally tweeted sup and
it was going Mega viral during like the
Bitcoin bull market right like literally
I could just breathe on the internet
everything went viral but like that's
not me and you have to be grounded
enough to understand like that's Bitcoin
bull market you know uh product that's
not because I'm some genius now when
that stuff crashes you know I have this
saying of like if you get the praise on
the way up you got to eat the [__] on
the chin on the way down and so like you
know you've eaten a lot of [__] because
you're you're so charismatic and you
make all these bold claims I mean you
get a lot of crap yeah but like if you
view that from the perspective like
these people are attacking me like
you'll be super depressed and you'll
like run away and be quiet a lot of
people do that when the Bitcoin you know
bear markets come or other asset markets
come like there are people who just
disappear right instead I look at those
opportunities as kind of a defiant way
to say like it does not matter what
happens I'm not leaving and so you know
in this last one when FTX blew up and
all this stuff happened I went on
national television and was grilled by a
reporter for 20 minutes and in a
completely unscripted thing he wasn't
friendly but it to me like that's where
my skill set shines is like I will
debate anyone at any time on topics that
I think I understand and it's even
better if it's on live TV because guess
what we did I went on television I did
it I got off Twitter was like on fire
people were like that was the greatest
segment of all time these two guys just
went at it and I emailed them and I said
send me the video I took the video and
immediately uploaded it to YouTube the
full thing and I said title pomp
destroys TV host on bitcoin and
published it
right and so like why go on television
it's to get the clips to get the content
to then post on your own stuff right so
I think that the hate you have to also
realize like oh like that's the
president of my marketing team that guy
there's a guy yesterday true story who
created an entire thread of hate he had
videos he had tweets he literally filmed
himself unfollowing me right like he
filmed his phone screen record
unfollowing me and I almost dm'd him and
said thank you right but I was just like
dude do you not understand how the
internet works the more you attack
people the bigger the audience gets and
I don't want to be attacked like I'm not
seeking controversy I'm not seeking to
be attacked but what ends up happening
is if you have that view of that lens
the haters are actually on your team
they just haven't realized it yet and so
like let them do their thing let them
keep hating and naturally the audience
gets bigger and bigger over time
what distribution channel is going to be
the most effective to you and the one
that you're when you talk about this
distribution and if you only had one of
them let's say Twitter email list
podcast YouTube which one would you say
this is the most powerful and this is
the one I'm focused on growing
so the one that I wouldn't give up is
the email uh but I don't necessarily
think that's the one I'm most focused on
growing I think that audio is a really
interesting medium where you're
basically whispering in someone's ear
for like an hour like it's super
intimate and people really come to trust
you and things like that
and so I think there's probably someone
out there like just doing reps at the
gym and just grunting right now and
listening to us right now we get that a
lot so we're in people's ears as they're
bench pressing I mean somebody's bicep
curling right now but also someone's
like literally at the bottom in their
deep Squat and they're like damn these
guys they're calling me out right now
right but like you're basically just uh
you're in people's ears or in email you
have direct communication and also you
can write like if you understand what
your best quality is some people is
writing some people it is video some
people it's just audio and talking I
know people who have podcasts who script
out every single word of the episode I
don't think you guys do that right and
like if you guys did do that one it
would take you guys forever but also two
like it wouldn't be as entertaining it
wouldn't be as fun and so it's kind of
trying to figure out like what is the
match between like the participant and
the medium so like if you guys were
sending an email and like you two wrote
it you didn't hire anyone like sorry but
it probably sucks right it would just be
like ah there's no magic here because
actually what makes this so magic is
that like there's the Serendipity and
the like iterative nature that you guys
have back and forth and so I just think
that as people start to get onto the
Internet and try to build these
audiences you gotta really question like
where is my advantage and where do I
actually have something that can cut
through the noise because now there's so
much noise if you don't cut through then
you might as well not get started
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
I'm exhausted
I'm just exhausted
I hate when you have to end the episodes
that way I just like that's how I feel
because like imagine imagine watching a
TV show and they're they're putting on a
show they're trying to have a good time
and at the end they're like
[Applause]
people will follow your lead if you had
a good time we'll have a good time you
got to have sound because we say
Showmanship a showman wouldn't be tired
at the end of his episode dude I'm not
down I'm amped and it's like I got to go
with like it's like it's like I just got
done working out I gotta go like rest
for a minute and get up and like
Implement all this stuff I feel like uh
I need to go like I I I'm maybe I'm into
crypto now I don't know like he he's
just Malcolm Gladwell my ass like I just
I just got got you know like I just feel
good about like what I heard and uh
you're just you're full of energy do you
nap are you a napper you don't nap no
hell no why would you nap don't nap [__]
to do oh
do you guys both take naps for real yeah
I'd nap every other day it's 99. every
day once I get to every day I know I
made it how many hours do you guys sleep
at night
seven normal same
oh man I don't think I could nap during
the day but I also drink uh coffee in
the morning so like I might screw it up
too I I gotta tell you guys a hilarious
story uh before we go so so pump was
talking about his like analyst team was
like you know the the high quality
analyst team that's all like you know uh
you know two years out of out of
undergrad and uh we at milk road we
basically had a super lean team it was
me Ben but I wasn't active day to day
really I was you know just kind of
guiding
um Ben was running it and then there was
a our lead Rider Diego who's awesome and
then we hired one guy we were like maybe
we should do social media and so we put
out a thing being like hey
um I don't know how to use Tick Tock but
if you do come work for us and so this
guy Billy uploaded this incredible video
it's on the it's on the internet you can
go look on Twitter basically you
uploaded a video of him just chugging
milk shirtless and just like doing it
was just like a ridiculous video he's
like he would find somebody like hey can
you hold this phone I'm trying to get a
job and then he would chug the milk and
they'd be like a job what is this and so
I anyways we hired Billy we tried to do
the tick tock thing didn't fully work
out but it was okay uh but Billy's
Billy's great guy he helped ended up
helping write the newsletter so two
hilarious things just happened first
they did a milk Road team off-site like
something we never did because my whole
ethos building the milk Road was like
I'm not trying to be a CEO anymore like
I'm not trying to like stand up in front
of the company with a t-shirt with our
name on and tell everybody how great
everything is like I just don't want to
even have to do all that stuff but the
the new guys who bought it they want to
do the company building so they invited
everybody out and uh I asked Ben I go
how was the offside he goes he had one
one Insight from the whole thing he goes
Billy showed up in a wife [__] but not
as a joke he just said that's just what
he wore to the event and no one said
anything and I was like no one said
anything I go wow that's incredible I
can't imagine not saying anything and
then let's fast forward three weeks uh
Billy they offered Billy a raise and he
quit instead and I was like it's a fan
goes Billy you you gotta raise and you
quit like this guy's a conundrum man
what's going on he goes he goes he goes
you quit like what's what's the plan he
just replied to bed in a text message he
goes do I look like a guy with a plan
that became the most badass thing I've
heard all week do I look like a guy who
has a plan but Sean I I tend to think
that we over index a lot on like uh
people want to always hang out with
their Heroes right they want to hang out
with the older people they want to hang
out with the people who have done the
thing that they're trying to do and
there's a lot of value you can get from
that but I do think that we drastically
under index on like go find the young
energetic person who you're like you are
literally an idiot but damn are you
gonna be an awesome idiot who's gonna
run through 20 walls and eventually find
something on the other side and what it
does is it like it forces you to up your
game have you ever talked to like a 21
year old and you're like okay so uh uh
let's get this done by Wednesday and
they're like okay and then they send it
back to you like two hours later and
you're like damn why do we wait till
Wednesday like this kid is actually
correct we should just get it done now
and so I do think that the internet
companies or these native companies
that's one of the big advantages they
have like I you know you guys had Nick
Huber you've had Andrew Wilkins stuff
like a bunch of people were doing this
when you find the right person who can
just like get [__] done you are
unstoppable with the internet now and I
think that that is something that more
and more people are going to wake up to
and like it wouldn't surprise me if we
like bankrupt Main Street businesses
because they all move online as people
just realize like why am I gonna have
like a physical store that people have
to walk into when I can just do this
online thing and it is a big concern for
these local communities but at the same
time like there's way more Economic
Opportunity online for uh for people who
want to do that
one of the other guys we tried to hire
at milk Road he was a young guy 20 21
years old he was working at Main Street
at the time and I love this guy's tweets
I thought he was interesting and he
would tweet out these like little random
websites he was making on the weekend
that were like just super simple like
kind of like it's either gonna go viral
or this is the dumbest thing ever uh
there's no in between there was no like
kind of core product service it made no
sense nothing it made any sense and I
was like dude I love this guy I told Ben
I was like hey we should hire this guy
he's like what's he gonna do I go I
don't know we should just have him do
what he's doing now but without his
full-time job like what if we just gave
him more time to do the stupid [__] he's
doing on the weekends Monday through
Friday instead and so he'll figure it
out I talked to him and I was like hey
uh you know here do that I think this
milk Road thing's gonna work it was
super early we were like I don't know
four weeks into it or something and I
was like I think this thing's gonna work
you should join he's the same thing what
am I gonna do I go just do do weird uh
you know Rohan stuff that you do go just
go ahead and do that and um he's like
all right cool let me let me like let
let me hit you up uh he's like he's like
when do you want to start like tomorrow
and I was like no no like I got like I'm
traveling I'm gonna be back on Wednesday
let's talk on Wednesday which is like
four or five days away
fatal mistake classic 34 year old
mistake thinking that that the world's
not going to change in four days this
guy's entire he in those four days he
ends up launching an nft project that
goes Super viral ends up making so much
money he goes and becomes this Anonymous
account Frank D gods
and he created the D Gods project I can
talk about it now because he's like out
publicly but for a while I was like why
[__] is this so I kept trying to hit him
up be like what happened I didn't know
he was the guy behind D gods and so I
was like dude what you ghosting me like
we were we had such a good idea he's
like hey man like three weeks later he
just resurfaced like sorry bro like like
it was like No Time had passed between
our conversations like oh yeah about
that
um I don't know man now I'm doing this
other stuff I gotta do this and I was
like tell me about it so he he screen
shares and he shows me how he's growing
it and one thing I'll never forget that
was like the classic like this is this
guy's an idiot this makes no sense but I
I'm down and I want to be in this car
um and so he shows me the site and I go
how do you stop people from just selling
it like you know right away like what
are you getting because nothing holds
value unless the the people who buy it
hold which is why like for Bitcoin the
genius meme is the the total meme right
because it became culturally the normal
thing to do to just hold the thing and
he goes oh yeah I had the same thought
so I created something called the paper
hands [__] tax and I go what basically
if you sell out a loss if you sell for
less than the mid price not only do you
get just like you know you take the loss
on the principle but we also apply a 25
tax because you had paper hands and we
applied the [__] tax to you for selling
on the dip and I was like he's like
people loved it
totally worked it became like again he
created a meme and it was a monetized
meme in his case and I just thought it
was awesome so yeah I'm totally down to
uh hang out with these guys Sean why all
this was happening uh I just looked at
my DMs so I have like a another
perspective on the exact same situation
which was uh one of the hacks that
people have figured out is if they post
something on their Instagram story like
a lot of times people with bigger
audiences would just like share it but
in the DMS it looks like they like
messaged you so now there's like they
posted something then you posted
something and so he did that and he uh
he posted something I reposted it and
then he followed up with he's gonna kill
me for reading this out loud he goes if
you have any ideas for some more fun
tools for us to make that you think
would be helpful would love to chat man
and he said it like we were like boys
right like he just like was kind of like
saying it like of course like you're
gonna engage so I didn't respond maybe I
didn't see it or whatever and so I guess
I went to LA uh for the Super Bowl and
then he follows it up with yo oh we
gotta kick it while you're out here
like again like we're like boys and I'm
like who is this like 20 something year
old kid right and so then he just keeps
messaging me until finally in July he
just starts dmming me things and he just
keeps saying yo and so I met him in
person of Miami and I was like who are
you basically and he's like oh I'm into
Bitcoin or whatever but like I have this
secret to tell you hey tell me about the
NFP thing and I was like what is going
on and he was showing up to conferences
with like handkerchiefs over his face
right I'm like I saw that guy's identity
and I was just like do you understand
how you cannot have like any degree of
success or uh reputation or anything to
be willing to like go to the lengths of
success that he went to and I think
that's why like young people are so
empowering to be around it's just like
that kid was willing to do a bunch of
stuff no matter how cool we think the
three of us are we would never do 50 60
of the things that he did because we're
like ah I can't do the paper hand [__]
Stacks because then everyone's like pop
[__] you you know like like yelling and
screaming or whatever this guy's just
like dude this would be hilarious watch
this
and it works and so I don't know it's
just like how do we find more of those
if you're like a young kid who has a
idea of like well Abraham [__] tax
please DM us I'll tell you I'll tell you
where I where I messed up so I had met I
think I think I told store I've told
stories on the pot about like four
people like this I basically had four
people that I kind of like either did
hire or were trying to hire as like a
really Junior kind of like intern Mentor
type type situation that have all gone
on to become like multi-millionaires
done super interesting things and I was
like how do I have more of this young
energy in my life because these people
are awesome they're flawed for sure they
do a lot of dumb [__] but the things
they do do are all it's always
interesting it's never boring right it's
like you know it's reality TV in a way
to me so I'm like all right I want to be
I I don't want to just get older and as
you become more successful you start
hanging out with older and older people
then you become old and so I'm like no
no I'm trying to fight that so I did
this dumb thing which was I tried to
recruit I tried to like put out the call
for people like this I was like hey if
you're young you're smart uh you know
like joint like yeah I just want to hang
with you I'll invest in your stuff or I
don't know I'll Mentor you I'll do
something I put out a type form and I
got all these smart people applying but
they were all the wrong people because I
had done it in a way that was like it
was like the high achiever path it was
like here's an admission form and
they're like ah a test I know how to win
the I know how to apply for things and
get picked and be like and so they just
said all the the right sounding things
which was here's my background here's my
pedigree they're well spoken and I
recruited like 20 of the wrong people
and I just had to like Abandon Ship I
was like okay I need to find a way to
get like the [__] and yeah they're
they're the wrong type of nerd exactly
like I don't want High achiever nerd
that's used to taking all the boxes and
getting good scores on all the
standardized uh standardized tests and
you know getting picked for the the the
like the thing that their parents wanted
them to do or School wants them to do
it's like you need the person who's gone
off the path you know will in the
bathroom at Target you know who's doing
the like Reckless Bitcoin stats and [__]
like that like you need you need
somebody who's a little bit off the path
uh because they're the ones who do more
interesting things and so I don't know I
haven't figured out how to recruit that
except for
um like referral basically I'm like who
do you hang out with it's Marshawn Lynch
there like his famous quote of like uh
I'm about that action boss about that
action boss yeah and like uh there's a
young person I know I won't use his name
or what he bill adult but people may be
able to figure it out
um he I think he like moved to Miami or
something uh or like was visiting Miami
maybe uh and I saw him on Twitter he was
like tweeting some interesting things I
just damned him I was like basically
like What's your deal right and uh
similar to Sam's like let's [__] I was
just like you're like What's your deal
and no I I usually say what what's your
story tell me your story
yeah
when I was in Austin we were texting and
he was like should we do dinner and I
responded with let's [__]
and he was like God damn it
um but so this kid he like comes to the
office and I don't know he's probably
like early 20s and he's literally like
yeah so me and my friend we like built
this app and it's been downloaded 75
million times it's like taking like
millions of dollars and I was like what
are you doing like like he's like yeah
I'm gonna like figure out a new thing to
do and I was like well what about the
thing that's working he's like oh it's
like on autopilot like I'm gonna like
figure out this new thing and I was just
like man you are so cool I hope that you
are so successful we need like a hundred
thousand of you in the world because he
literally could care less about the
money and like all that stuff he just
was like how do we build cool [__] and
so I was like man imagine if one of us
had built an app that had 75 million
downloads we'd be talking about it
non-stop like that'd be our tires
better update my LinkedIn
endorse my skill
dude I have the craziest versions so I
know we're way over but I gotta tell the
story it's too good so that guy Rohan
I'm like how do I meet more people like
him so my strategy was let me just hang
out with him and I told him bring a
friend so he drives from La down to San
Diego to where we're hanging out at this
house and he brings a friend of course
the friend is you know the 24 year old
version of the Dos Equis guy he's the
most interesting man in the world so
this guy comes in and I'm like all right
What's your deal guy who like you know
has curly hair and maybe still has
pimples like yo you must be the best and
he of course was the best so he he's
like yeah my name's Luca and I'm like
what's your story and he goes
so I went in reverse order because he
brought in these guns like these uh Nerf
type guns like gel blasters I don't know
if you've seen this but like it's a gun
called the gel Blaster it's basically
like um they're everywhere yeah it's
everywhere now I didn't realize it's
like a 50 million a year business so he
basically was like oh right now I'm
working on this like d2c product this
like you know thing oh yeah we just
we're in Walmarts Nationwide or you know
I don't know some some [__] like that
where basically it's like if you're 13
year old years old this is your like
number one thing you want for Christmas
it was like this it's kind of like less
painful than a paintball gun but like
cooler than a Nerf gun where it's just a
foam thing it's like this little pellet
that's like a gel pellet and it shoots
like a machine gun so already he brought
two over the party became way more fun
people are shooting each other it's
great so I'm like all right you're doing
this that's crazy he's like yeah you
know I was trying to do this but then we
got ripped off we got sued by this one
thing blah blah all right what'd you do
before this he goes oh yeah I'm into
crypto that's why I know you know why I
know you guys you know um I bought pudgy
Penguins so he did like a hostile
takeover
of pudgy Penguins this nft project which
again
it's not what you're it's you know you
don't usually think I'm gonna go spend
millions of dollars to buy pudgy
Penguins nft IP but he decided that that
was a good use of time I said how'd you
get millions of dollars and he goes well
before that I um I started this online
e-commerce brand where I was selling
gold chains you know like rappers gold
chains and grills and [__] like that I
go what he's like yeah I just like I
just realized that you could just buy
these like kind of crazy blinged out
rapper gold chains and like uh and I
sold them and then I sold my company to
this company shop GLD which uh which
does like 300 400 million a year I was
like 300 or 40 I've seen these people
like sponsor you know like kind of like
you know random Instagram influencers
I'm like wow this is all crazy I go how
did you get started doing that and I got
one level deeper he goes well I um I had
to like you know for family reasons you
know me and my mom were like homeless
for a couple years and I had to like oh
my God he's like I just quit school in
high school and I had to go make money
so I went down the street and I started
knocking on doors trying to get a job I
got rejected everywhere the last door I
knocked on was a startup called ring and
the guy Jamie was was there as a tiny
office and he's like who are you what do
you need he's like I need a job badly
like to help pay like for family stuff
uh I'll do anything and he's like okay
well I got like I gotta box up all these
orders can you just help me with that
and so he like started boxing up the
orders he was like the first employee at
ring and then was like with Jamie for a
few years before going off and doing his
own thing and I was like but now he is
your son so this was adopted or like 25
he was like 24 25 when I met this guy
you know a couple months ago and I'm
like you have lived three lifetimes in
in of career epicness and just really
interesting things like I can't wait to
see what this guy is going to do next
but like that to me is the future right
is like all these young people who have
that skill set it's not for everyone
like some people just want to go be the
accountant or go be you know kind of a
mid-level manager and that's their
career aspiration that's fine
um but for the people who want to do
this like that guy literally knows more
about business and like IP and you know
uh physical store distribution and like
all these things then most people coming
out of NBA schools right like good for
that kid
100 100 and I was like hey uh I'm trying
to think about influencers and I just I
literally felt like someone being like
uh like it's like if some it's like when
my grandfather comes to me yeah they're
they're gonna start calling you gray
bush yeah exactly well it's like it's
like I've helped my grandfather like set
up FaceTime you know just so he could
see his grandkids and it's like and it's
like uh I don't know just push the green
button like that's all that's as far as
you're gonna get here like that's how I
felt by the end of talking to this guy
about how to like how to do online
marketing through like influences on
Instagram like by the end of it he was
like you know what just like send me the
link dude I'll take care of it for you
you know you're not gonna you're not
gonna be able to do this stuff
dude that's crazy these are these are
some good stories I'm I'm back the
Energy's back baby
should we just go forever like just do
like a 10 hour rip see this would be
like 30 of Pomp's Morning Show he would
still be sitting there with his brothers
yeah we can talk like two hours of air
time to fill you want to know the
craziest part about the morning show is
the greatest thing I ever did and the
worst thing I ever did because it took
so much time to your point but man there
is no better thing than just hanging out
like imagine if we every single day just
live stream for two hours about whatever
the [__] was going on you had never had
more fun than doing stuff like that the
problem is you start to just say what's
actually on your mind and like
real doll later one time I was on one
time I was on your show and I like
totally ruined it for your sponsor do
you remember that no what'd you do I
think you had Sofi on as like a sponsor
yeah and I I
uh like something wasn't going well with
them and I was like so far more like so
[__] and uh
I saw your face freak out and I go oh
wait so far marketing people if you're
listening to this this is me Sam I'm
saying this not pop so don't don't yell
at him do you guys suck or something
they were incredible and uh it was like
they had the stadium and the whole thing
but like you know how it is right
there's probably people who have said
things about sponsors or like maybe a
company you're an investor in or
whatever and you're always like man I
wish you hadn't said that but like here
we go and that was definitely one of
those moments where I was just like well
there's a lot worse things that Sam
could have said so like I guess on the
grand scale of like what is possible
that was like not great but still you
know we'll just keep moving here
you've got the the Donald Trump thing
where it's like if you're crazy from the
beginning if you just say wild [__] all
the time there's no penalty it's only
like pop you you're a little too smart
and like responsible if you slip up even
a little people are gonna get on you but
like if you're just wild all the time
there is no penalty you somehow get out
of jail free and I think I I've been
trying to steal that from Sam now of uh
how to how to just keep it keep it loose
and somehow like Sam does it to guess
they'll come on and be like
you know you're really good looking for
like an ugly Tech Guy
spinning or he'll just be like
[Laughter]
Sean you'll appreciate this whenever
people make them no whenever people are
like hey uh I want to start a podcast
and I'm like kind of talking through
with them for a few minutes in terms of
like what to do I use Sam as an example
so I'm like well you can have like you
know a show where you just talk yourself
you can have like an interview show and
then like within those different
categories like you know you can have a
really serious intelligent podcast where
you ask really smart questions uh or you
can be like really blunt like you know
Sam par like he'll just have guests come
on and just be like how much money is
your bank account
I always think of like man fifty percent
of people are like ah I'm good I'm not
gonna answer that and then 50 like
literally tell you the answer and I'm
like what a genius way to get great
content it's just like ask the questions
that no one will answer then he'll
follow up with something that's like
well and the reason I ask is because
because I want to know
it's like there's more justification but
there's just none because I'm always
curious like you know I've been
following you for years and I just I was
I was curious like what is it
well in that book influence they say
they say if you if you if you give
someone a reason for why you're doing
something they're more likely to do it
right so I got in the habit of saying
like yeah and I'm asking that because
I'm curious right it doesn't matter what
comes out
because it's just a magic word all right
can I ask you guys one question before
we uh before we break here yeah
can each of you point who's the one
person that's like on the internet so
not like you know Mark Zuckerberg or
Jeff Bezos or whatever who's like the
one internet entrepreneur that you're
like man that person seems to have
figured it out and like I can't wait to
see what they continue to do over the
next 20 30 years and like extra points
if it's somebody that no one really
knows my obvious one is Huber but Nick
Huber but let me think about let me
think about why is that I don't think
that would have been obvious why is it
well everyone knows them um I also think
that uh if I had to bet money on like
one operator
um I think it would be Austin reef at
morning Brew like I've gotten to know
him really well and he's one of the few
people I'm like afraid of them like if I
hear that I'm gonna compete with them I
would be like [__] it's on so he he I
would say those two but let me try to
think of someone who's a little bit more
Anonymous what about you Sean let me ask
you different question pop before I
answer what would be the what would be
the type of answer that would be
interesting to you here
is it just somebody who like either
nobody knows or somebody who's been like
successful doing something that isn't
like oh I set up a newsletter and now I
have a bunch of like ad Revenue like the
the pellet gun you know is like
fascinating right you're just like man
who even knew that was a market so like
somebody who's out uh kind of out of the
mainstream all right here's one we have
this we both have a friend but I'm gonna
hurry up and say it so Sean doesn't
there's a guy named Mark Jenny
um who started this company called RV
share and he sold it for hundreds of
millions of dollars now he owns like 50
million dollars worth of airbnbs and
we'll like message them like hey do you
want to come on the Pod he's like oh I
can't for the next three months I'm
traveling the world with my kids and
their home school their homeschooling
teachers talk later and uh he uh I think
he's he's kind of one of the guys who I
look at who's just kind of won life and
the last one is the guy who started um
WP uh forms what's it called Sean it's
called Syed uh he started um this
company that owns maybe a hundred
million dollar years a hundred million
dollar a year business where he owns all
these WordPress forms any or WordPress
plugins and he says he works five days a
week so one day a week one day a month
or one week a month he takes the
meetings with all of his CEOs and
besides that he's giving away a lot of
his money and he's like 30 years old
married with kids super low-key
that's a great answer Sean I'll give you
a couple names that come to mind so I
think
um so amjad from replit I think he's
sitting on a monster business that is
kind of hidden in plain sight like
people know about it but it's not yet
considered to be big just because they
haven't come out with a really flashy
headline of being worth X billions of
dollars like I think when they raised
their last round it was at almost like
strategically
shy of a billion number it was like 800
and something million instead of a
billion I'm sure they could have
negotiated it up but I actually really
like that he didn't and it's one of
these things that's just like I think
it's a I think it's just going to be a
really important company and I think
it's going to be different than uh
um
I think it's gonna be different than the
previous winners looked like because uh
you know like what happens is uh you
know Amazon takes off then you think the
next big thing is going to be e-commerce
but no it's actually Google and Google
takes off that you think the next thing
should be search and information no it's
actually Facebook it starts off as like
a college social network thing then you
think Facebook's the big thing and then
actually turned out to be Uber it was
like you know Uber and Airbnb it was
like real world [__] that you can use
your phone as a magic button to do so
it's kind of like the next interesting
thing is not going to look like what the
last interesting things look like and I
think that uh what replant is which is
this like coding environment for
oftentimes beginners teenagers
um I think is like a stealth really
really big deal uh but it's kind of
boring so I wouldn't say like I wouldn't
say he's the one I'm looking at because
I kind of know what he's going to do for
the next 10 years I almost don't have to
look it's like I could just check in and
tell yours and be like yep the hockey
step the hockey stick kept going and
like you know obviously that that had
big implications
I'm an investor sure and replit and I
think that you're spot on of like it's
way bigger than people realize but also
uh the most important thing is like they
capture new coders and then they try to
keep them in that environment and so
like if they get you early on it's like
kind of like going to like the source
yeah it's just like that's your lifetime
infrastructure it's a fascinating
business I'm an idiot and should have
invested so much more money because uh I
completely agree it's gonna be a massive
massive company so who are the other
ones Sean uh the other ones so I would
have said a couple years ago Sam Altman
but now I think that's obvious so I'm
going to say somebody who I think is on
par with Sam Altman but doesn't have the
same shine and doesn't have the clear
like open AI type of like interesting
bit which is Daniel gross So Daniel
gross is one of the more most
interesting and impressive people that
I've met
um I think that he fits your category
because he's still young enough
he's ambitious super super ambitious
like Sam Altman but he's free he's not
like currently committed to like one
company for like a really long time or
like in the middle or you know hasn't
like picked one path that he has to stay
in and so I just can't imagine that in
the next 10 years Daniel gross doesn't
do something that is like just Epic uh
and I think it could be in some field
that you don't that maybe he's not even
working in today could be like longevity
or some biohacking thing so I think that
you need people who are willing to go
into these other spaces that pull off
some impressive [__] I think by bio and
like sort of this longevity Space is
really interesting and there's going to
be some tech entrepreneur that's like
forget like you know forget the
newsletter podcast Twitter forget
software with VCS forget investing I'm
gonna go and do something else with my
time and I like people who just choose
to play their own game and ideally a
game that not everybody else is playing
I think Daniel gross is going to be that
guy
that's a great one and he is kind of
like hidden in plain sight but I think
that Sam was at the same time like he
came on our podcast really early on like
at the hustle's office he's I don't even
know how we got him on we just I don't
even know who knows it maybe me or
you're saying I don't remember but he
just walked in I don't think he had any
idea what we were doing I'm pretty sure
we like shared a microphone like we did
the thing where you I think we were on
our iPhone I'm gonna pass it to you like
we were down definitely down One mic
It's like because we only never done two
people uh episodes it was this tiny room
and we're seeing like uh airpods little
table like you you know like it looks
like Lunchables should be on top of the
table like it was that baby of a table
and our show is not for everybody it's
not like you could sit down most people
like cool let's brainstorm like what's
what's an interesting startup idea you
have what what are some spaces you think
are cool why do you think this is going
to work and this guy was able to riff
for like two hours on everything from
like running to why somebody should
create a new Apple competitor with
creating a new laptop to his investing
strategy why it's different like how
he's going to beat YC all these
different topics and he just went for
like two hours effortlessly and I
thought okay that's impressive that's
you know the type of person I like to
follow and be around
but is is that like a signal you
actually should surround yourself with
one young people but two is like the
most interesting people you can find
like I hate going to dinner Sam and I
was talking about this uh when we went
to dinner like I hate going to like the
classic business dinner where I was like
oh what do you do what's going on at
work whatever like I love the person who
shows up to dinner and they have some
wild thing that makes everyone disagree
and argue and and like uh uh debate
what's gonna happen and this and that
whatever and then you find like the
person who has that usually has like a
whole bag of them right like they
literally are like oh okay we're done
talking about this one like here's my
next you know Ace out of my back pocket
and those people somehow always figure
out how to be successful like very
rarely do you find the like most
interesting man kind of like the kid
with the gun right that ends up not
figuring it out they may fail a hundred
times but eventually they do it and is
that just like they think differently
and that is kind of the prerequisite to
actually finding true success
yeah an independent mindedness like Jack
Smith was the other guy I was gonna say
because he's like this I don't know pop
do you know Jack no who's that he's uh
Jack Smith he started fungal which was
like a big ad Network
um but he's a kind of young British guy
who is I think he sold that company for
900 million dollars when he was 28 years
old and and so he but but like
if you talk to him he'll never mention
it because it's not because he's being
humble like he is humble but it's
because it's just not interesting to him
I don't know even though if it was
interesting he left like a few years
before it sold because he's like cool
I'm gonna do whatever and anytime you
talk to Jack he's up to a new as Sam
would call a new Caper and it's like uh
it's not like
usually for profit like sometimes it's
for profit but it's more like dude Jack
you don't care about this money he's
like but I'm trying to beat this game
and so like one time you'll talk to him
and he'll be like he spent the last two
months in his garage trying to build the
perfect computer chair it's like the
like like the thing or zero gravity like
floating on your back chair and he tried
every product he's tinkering with it
until he gets it right and the next time
you talk to him he's like really into
the world of Collectibles and he's like
got this Arbitrage going where he's
buying and selling baseball cards and
you're like Sam you're like Jack do you
even know about baseball he's like
couldn't tell you the first thing about
baseball but I could tell you that this
card right here is undervalued and my
like team in the Philippines is like
flipping him right now for profit then
the next time
he made like a list where he put in a
spreadsheet all the companies that you
can buy a pair of clothing from and you
could return it within 365 days he's
like I want to see if I can like live
for free for a year off these clothes
off this clothes they can return it or
you know just like weird schemes he just
loves or like he had a baby and then he
didn't name the baby
they just called it baby for the first
year until the baby could pick its own
name by crawling to like one of the
names I was like this guy's not gonna do
anything in the like just Standard
Version and he's not doing any of these
like he's not talking about them we are
the ones who talk about them maybe he
doesn't even want to maybe we should
take that out but like he doesn't do it
for the effect like he just does it
because he just got curious about that
path or wanted it to like just thought
that makes more sense to him than the
other way and then he'll do it and he's
not like what you don't want is the guy
who's at the dinner to immediately say
the crazy thing because they're like
trying to seem a little bit out there
and like they're trying to build their
brand like that's the worst you want the
person who's almost aloof to the fact
that it sounds batshit crazy and you're
like dude do you realize what you're
saying and they're like what what's
wrong with that well by the way the baby
thing was like the I I made fun of
Michael Jack for once in your life be
normal and then um like I I you know
like the time passed and I was like
that's actually a great idea because he
said he goes why would I name my kid
before I even know them I should like
see like what type of name fits and I
was like
oh yeah you're actually right it is
weird that like we don't get to know
them and so anyway he does things all
the times where at first glance I'm like
this is the stupidest thing ever just be
normal for once and then he'll uh
hell like I I actually think he's right
A lot of times
I I think I think there's like
somebody who
has that proclivity of like always doing
things in a different way
one it isn't necessarily different to
them but two is that
those individuals are the ones who
actually end up figuring out like what
is the best chair or they're the one who
like they'll convince a whole friend
group to like not name their kids for a
year or you know what I mean like
there's almost this like lack of uh
importance we put on uh the courage to
be different so like even in friend
groups like do you ever notice like
everyone thinks something and then once
one person says uh something else then a
bunch of people like flip and they're
almost like just like kind of like oh
where's the magnet right like oh this
Viewpoint is popular like they just kind
of Mosey on over here and then like this
other person said this they Mosey on
over there and so I do think that we
need those people in a society but also
like man what a boring friend group it
would be to have where like everyone
just gets together on Friday night like
what'd you do this week I don't know
went to work right right like what are
you doing this weekend like I don't know
gonna like just watch the games like it
it just would not be fun and so I think
that a lot of people who listen to this
podcast but also just like are
quote-unquote on the internet their
escape being what could be like their
local life of that and they're trying to
find other interesting people they're
trying to find other ideas and it's like
exhilarating for them and so like this
Jack guy sounds amazing but like how do
you find a hundred of them
well it's usually fine and then you just
realize that they're going to do this
forever like there's this one Russian
guy who started this social network back
in the day called Kube I don't know if
you ever saw it but like Kube was Tick
Tock before Tick Tock it was amazing it
was only in Russia Ukraine
um I only found out about it because I
randomly met up with this group from
Ukraine that was touring the touring
Silicon Valley and I was like hey come
to our office I'll give you a talk and I
at the end I asked him I was like what's
the hot [__] in Ukraine that I should be
knowing about I don't even know why I
asked this question turned out to be a
great question but I didn't really
expect them to have a good answer but
they're like this thing called Coop
blowing up and this is like two years
before Tick Tock and um and so anyways
he built that thing it it didn't end up
going huge I think because of other
reasons like with Russia and the way
they control things but uh I'm like this
guy's gonna only always do interesting
things so last week I checked it I was
like what's that guy Anton doing of
course he's doing the craziest [__] so
he now is doing
he's like I'm trying to change the way
people eat fruit
you ever seen someone eat a mango cut a
mango
disgusting okay what he goes the way
Americans eat mangoes is terrible a
mango is he's like this goes on this
he's like mangoes are beautiful they're
the most delicious thing and he has
basically he did this he has some
process that cuts like the juiciest part
of a mango into a perfect little ball
and so you could you look at it you're
like that looks delicious and basically
his mission is to make fruit more fun
and delicious to eat by just cutting it
better and you cut it better and you
package it that way you you store it in
a certain way he's like I'm gonna
reinvent the way people eat fruit and
I'm like of course you are of course guy
who created
now gonna change the way I eat like
mango but like you know sure enough like
he's gonna just keep doing interesting
things he can't not
that's an investor thesis weird [__]
that makes money it's amazing pomp
you're messaging me before this and
you're like it's only an hour right and
I was like yeah give or take and uh give
or take an hour uh this is now our
longest episode ever I think hopefully
you didn't miss any meetings we're gonna
we're gonna break this up into two
episodes I think I think we have two two
episodes I think I think because the
first thing was awesome and the second
thing was it was awesome this is a I
don't want people to miss the the second
half the second half was maybe better
than the first half
well you guys were too kind I uh I
listen every week I always enjoy
listening to you guys give each other
[__] and then having things funnier
well see the whole thing about humor is
that you guys have your moments but I
just enjoy what I enjoy when the uh when
the guests come on and then you both you
can just feel it like uh one time I
heard uh Joe Rogan and Naval on uh on
the podcast and I said to my wife I was
like man Joe Rogan's super smart but
like this is like a Ferrari and a
Corolla you know like literally like
Paul was just like he was like hitting
his a game right and even Joe was just
kind of like hmm tell me more
we go and uh sometimes I can feel you
guys are like man you guys are just
absolutely killing it and then a guest
comes on you're like hmm tell me more
and you just let them ride so I
appreciate all the work you guys are
doing and uh you give me a little
something to listen to every morning Sam
the funnier guy is the one who didn't
have to ask who's funnier just so you
know
it's a general rule
it's better than you I don't know man
who's uglier which uh which I'm sure is
the next question
I don't know man I get texts I get at
least one text a month saying I'm a
hilarious have you guys done the
analysis of who talks more
somebody in the audience probably could
do it
and then you can argue with him yeah we
don't even need data science we don't
need will Clemente at Target to know
this one
talk and interrupt more
this is great uh what were you saying
you were saying that everybody should
subscribe to our Channel or they're
gonna lose all their money or something
like that something
if you don't fulfill the gentleman's
agreement like what's going on come on
the gentleman's agreement and the ladies
understanding the lady's understanding
exactly what you guys should start
telling people is like help me help you
you know is uh
yeah I get the uh get the video in the
feed now that uh Susan CEO of uh YouTube
has stepped down Neil has stepped in
he's bringing back all the distribution
he's going to send you guys to the moon
so don't uh don't worry I wish I could
uh be on a first name basis with these
people I mean it's like what do you like
what do you you're like a you called
Dave Matthews Band Dave too well the
beauty is you just call them by their
first name and then they similar to
Rohan dming me you just think that your
boys and so I'm hoping that maybe
they'll uh turn our volume up a little
bit on YouTube oh Susan
is actually a really funny story very
quickly uh oh what is um what is the guy
who uh he used to walk around with uh
the clock what is that guy's name
Flavor Flav so uh I'm pretty sure yeah
I'm like almost 99.9 sure with him uh I
was working at Facebook Joe Montana came
to like do like this veterans event and
so they need like an escort kind of like
a almost like a babysitter for any guest
who comes on campus so another guy was
going to take Joe Montana and they were
like hey you uh are gonna go with Flavor
Flav and I was like oh that sounds cool
like okay so I'm like walking around
with them kind of like nervous to talk
to him because he's you know like a
celebrity but also like is he cool is he
not whatever do the event and at the end
he goes yo before I leave where's that
Instagram doodad and I was like what and
he was like the Instagram dude and I was
like uh and he was like the Instagram
Guy where is he I know he works here and
I was like do you mean like the founders
and he was like yeah the tall one I met
him I know him and I was like oh boy
and so he was like I was like uh Kevin
and he was like uh yeah that one so I'm
like I genuinely I generally know where
the Instagram team said so I like walk
through the whole campus right we get
there and I'm like please don't be at
your desk please don't be at your desk
please don't be at your desk right never
talked to the guy before and then uh
sure enough he's like there he's like
taller than everyone you could see him
the second you walk in the door I got
Flavor Flav with me and I walk over and
I go uh excuse me Kevin uh uh
is like oh man what's up like whatever
and he's like super nice to him and
just goes what's up yo you need to turn
my volume up on Instagram
and I'm like I'm definitely getting
fired like holy [__] this is so bad and
uh and Kevin was like a consummate
professional he's like let me go like
introduce to our Partnerships team like
whatever and I remember like on my way
out I was like hey man sorry about that
like did you know him he was like I
think we met like one time like five
years ago at a party but like sure and
so I always just think about like yeah
if you ever get to talk to the leaders
of any of these products like that's the
question that you gotta ask you gotta
shoot your shot it's like yo turn my
volume up that's so good that's my new
phrase that and do I look like a guy
with a plan
those are just those are just epic all
right fellas appreciate it
[Music]
thank you